- I remember,
growing up in a neighborhood,
an old neighborhood.
You know, I grew up on a block
where we all hung together
and we all stuck together and
we did everything together,
we spent the night at each other houses,
we ate at each other's houses.
You know, we played
football in the streets, tag
and we were a close knit group.
There was like eight of
us, eight boys, my age,
back then growing up.
And, you know, we were
like two peas in a pod.
And what happened was, I started.
You know what, I said I
would try everything once,
at least one time
and it started with
the beer and marijuana.
I think I started drinking at 11,
about the same time I started
to experiment with marijuana.
Tried PCP once, heroin and
all that kind of stuff,
crack came a lot later.
And, you know, growing up, single parent,
scared to death of being
in the ghetto, you know.
And that's like I said,
right when I turned 14 or 15
that's when the game epidemic, it just,
it out of nowhere it just came down.
There was like, man, you know,
they was using these words and you know,
you can't say this word,
you can't say that word.
I'm like, what?
'Cause I used to use this
word called blood something.
It a term, but it was like
saying brother man,
but it had blood in it.
And I remember my cousin telling me, say,
Hey Eric, hey man, uh uh,
you can't use that word,
man, you can't use that.
You know, you have to use this word
and he said it, I'm like what?
I said, okay, okay.
Okay yeah, I can do that.
But it felt funny, you know,
'cause just out the blue
and shortly after that,
here came the crack cocaine.
But leading up to the crack man, I was up,
man, I was a beer connoisseur, you know.
And I love the best money can buy
when it came to marijuana.
You know, I remember I'm
being busted to the Valley
from elementary, junior
high and high school,
dropped out in 10th grade,
but I used to go out there to the Valley
and Wilton Hills, when I was at Taft.
And come back with the tie bud
and it was that weed
that was tied to a stick
by a thin stream.
Man, I used to come home with the tie bud,
the indica, the purple hair.
And it was real sticky in it,
it smells so strong.
The fellows in the neighborhood
used to go like, wow
and used to give me their money.
For me to take the school the next day,
to purchase some for everybody.
So, we would all put our
little money together
and I'd take it and I'd go to school
and I cop and I bring it
back to the neighborhood man,
and now we'd party, like
there was no tomorrow.
So, I'd smoke and drink
beer with the bandit man,
from 11 to like, 20, 23, 24.
And that's when the crack hit the scene
and that shit got ahold of me so fast,
I didn't know what hit me.
All I remember is taking one hit
and never filling the same.
It took me somewhere that
the marijuana and the alcohol
just couldn't.
It was like I had an
outer body experience.
But to keep a 100 with you,
when I took that hit I felt
like cumming to myself,
felt like I nutted.
And that's what I liked about it.
I ain't felt that, you know, man,
you know, I consider myself
a freak back in the days
as a youngster, you know.
I was taking down, all women, young, old,
I didn't give a damn about the color,
none of that stuff.
I was just trying to hit
everything that I could,
you know, 'cause that's what I was taught,
that's the way I was raised, you know.
The more women you have, the
more success you are as a man.
You know, it's like carved stripes
on your own you're belt
buckle or something like that.
You know, when I had
about three, four women
from 14 to my twenties,
you know, about three,
four women at one time,
you know, in different areas.
Have one in the Valley, two in
neighborhood, one cross town.
And I was juggling, but you know,
it saw it work, man, it wasn't easy.
So, I developed the art
of a manipulation, lying,
cheating of course, cheating, stealing,
you know, I had to
provide for these women.
So, this one wanted this,
so I had to go to the store
steal this for her, you know,
and this one for this one
and all that, 'cause I couldn't afford it.
But, once the crack came in and took me
where I never thought I'd go man,
and the first hit, man,
it took a hold of me and wouldn't let go.
You know, I remember
blowing out the smoke and
all my problems went away.
I wasn't poor no more, I
wasn't in ghetto no more,
I wasn't worthless, you know,
I was somebody, you know.
I was somebody from another planet,
because I damn sure don't
want to be on earth.
You know, I really didn't
man, on the inside.
So, from that first hit I fell in love
and it was a love, hate relationship, man.
It took me many places, many dark places
and it left some scars
that forever be with me,
but you can't see them,
because they're on the inside.
I remember,
inside the family it's
a whole nother story
inside the household.
More so, than being on the streets
and dealing with the fellas.
I love being on the streets,
I love doing everything the kids did
and all that kind of stuff.
But, the real reason why I
drunk and smoke marijuana,
because me and my brother,
we never got along,
we never saw eye to eye.
There was always something
going on with me and my brother.
I remember my mom working
and she would leave us home,
you know, I come home from
school, he'd be there.
And I remember one time
I was in the living room,
listing to my radio and he
said, Hey, turn it down,
you're playing it too loud.
I turned it down.
Let me show you how low I had it.
I'm laying on the floor in a living room.
With my head pressed up
and against the radio,
listing to it.
He came out the bedroom,
snatched my radio up
put it on the ground and stumped on.
I'm like, you got to be kidding me.
You know, I'ma say this and
I'm gonna leave it alone,
when it comes to him.
I remember one time, I
don't know what I did.
He chased me out the house once
in my underwear, my tudor
looms in broad daylight.
I didn't have no shirt, no
shoes, no socks, no pants,
just my underwear, bare footed.
I think like 3:30, four
o'clock in the afternoon.
I hit them stairs, hit the porch,
hit the middle of the street and take off,
like the road runner.
And he's chasing me, he
can't catch me, I'm too fast.
And I never forget all the
neighbors were outside,
young and old and they
would just watch me.
It's like I was running in slow motion,
looking past all these
houses as I'm running
and seeing all these people just looking,
you know, like,
and I'm running for my dear life.
I'd never forget that.
So, I use marijuana and I use beer
to gain that confidence, so
I can stand up and be tough
and beat that man, you know.
'Cause like I said, man,
growing up I was a mama's boy,
always was, always will be.
And it gave me the courage, you know,
just to stand up and talk back.
You know, I didn't break it her stuff
and do all that kind of
stuff as far as retaliation.
But, you know, I started
speaking up, you know
I start standing up for
myself and as what it gave me,
it gave me that, that false
courage, but it was enough.
'Cause I needed something, you know,
to deal with that day-to-day thing.
Where you know, just the
sibling rivalry, man,
I don't know what it was, with
me and my older brother, man,
I think his thing was he wanted to,
he was the big brother,
but he wanted to play
the father role in a family, you know.
It was my sister, Tracy, Todd, and me.
Now, Tracy is the
oldest, Todd's the middle
and I'm the baby.
So, he felt like he was obligated
to be that father figure
also slash big brother.
But the father figure didn't work.
You know, it just didn't work.
You know, 'cause he was
crossing boundaries man.
You know, and over and over again,
crossing those boundaries.
And I remember running away
and staying gone till my
mom come home from work.
As soon as my mom get home
I let in on her ass,
curse her the fuck out.
Why weren't you there to protect me?
Why weren't you da, da, da?
You know.
What the fuck man?
This motherfucker's crazy, mad man.
Got me up in here with this mother..
And I'm a kid man,
and when she come home
from work, I let in on her.
Call her the B word, all that stuff.
Hurting so motherfucking bad,
because she couldn't help me.
I said, mans, you know.
It was her job, that's the
way I though back then,
that's how I feel.
You know, she let me
down, you let me down.
You know, every time I tell you
with some account or some,
she thought it was just like, we just,
you know, we just, you
know, just like kid stuff.
But, you know, my thing is
it ain't nothing kid about
anytime we get into it,
anything in that immediate area
he'll grab it and he'd come at me with it.
Shoes, a baseball bat, a telescope,
that the four point that you put on,
grab that up and came at me once, plates.
Anything, books, anything in
arms, you know, arms reach.
And here I go again, I'm
taking off, road runner
and over and over again.
Man, I used to stay out all night
just to keep from going home.
So, I had to escape my reality,
because I didn't know what else to do.
You know, when people
didn't see it like I saw it,
but it was always something going on,
there was always something, you know.
Let me tell you something,
my brother, he was a sharp dresser.
So, he will wear his clothes.
He would go to school with
his cloths on, come back,
the next day, while he's still sleep,
I would grab his shirt and pants
out the dirty clothes hamper,
put them on and go to school.
'cause I liked the way he dressed and
I want want to be like him.
Now, mind you, if I come home from school
and he's home and he
seen me in his clothes,
he's tear my up.
Like, man, what you doing
with my clothes on, man?
Man, I just, you know,
and here we go again,
you know, and I'm here losing.
But I tried to, you know,
I love my brother, I do.
We never got along, but
that don't take away
that I love him, you know.
But, I just wanted to,
I want to be like them in ways where,
we never talked at home,
we never had that bond.
We didn't do the baseball thing together.
We didn't do the football together.
We didn't do the movies together.
We didn't do anything together.
You know, I remember him playing football
and his partners just said, Hey, Hey,
why don't you let your
little brother come along?
Ah, nah, you know?
And that just used to
kill me, I didn't let on.
But I used to say, Hey, Hey,
hey, tell him, can I come with you guys
to the game tonight?
You know, it's the championship game.
The four top teams in Los Angeles
is playing at the sports arena, you know?
And back in the days I remember it was
Carson, Banning, Van Heusen.
I remember one year LA high,
my brother's friend made it
Los Angeles, LA University.
But I always remember Carson and Banning.
And then, one year my cousin Thomas
he made it to the championship game
at the sports arena, Jefferson.
You know, Jefferson High School, man.
And it was like, man, that was like
that was like, going to the super bowl.
You know, for me being
a kid and getting ready
going into high school.
You know, just having
that dream of playing
at the sports arena in
a championship game.
The top four teams in California,
you know, playing for it all.
And that was the only
thing that in my mind
that was driving me back then,
it was driving me, you know.
But I had my hands full,
but that was the only
thing that really kept me
kind of like thinking, oh
yeah, there's a way out
and I'm going get my ass up outta here.
You know, and I thought
it'd be through football.
You know, I was fast, had
practice at that at a early age.
You know, had all the moves and all that,
you know, can shake you,
do the dance and all that.
And I learned that the hard way.
But nonetheless, you know,
it served to help me later.
But any who, one day, woke up
and there was somebody,
Hey, check this out, man.
Yeah, we're gonna try this cocaine.
I'm like, what?
Said, yeah man, said, they call it rock.
I'm like, what is it?
They said, well, what they do is,
the rich folk eat the base, but we
from the ghetto, we're
going to crush it up,
we're gonna sprinkle it over
some marijuana or cigarettes.
And we're going to call this the primo.
I said, okay.
Rolled it up and we all.
I said damn, okay, I like that.
You know.
We used to break up,
there was eight of us.
So, you know, everybody
had their own hustle.
You know, me and my crew.
You know, we were notorious,
you know, for hustling
in the parking lots.
You know, we was notorious
for, you know, we was good.
You know, we mastered the art of that.
Everybody had their own little
specialty that they did.
So, we would all meet on the corner
and two would go off here, drive away,
two would go this way and we
would go towards USC, you know.
And had a football and all that stuff
and we get a hustle on, come
back and we all meet back up
we go get us the rock,
made sure we had marijuana.
Okay, we got $25, cool.
Get the $20 rock, get
the nickel bag of weed,
we're gonna roll two big monster joints,
my bad, primos, cool.
So, that's what we did.
And lo and behold, it
just became a daily thing.
Soon as I get home from school, let's go,
you know, we're gone.
I couldn't wait to do that primo,
I'd be in school man.
Well I wouldn't be in
school, I'd be playing
Centipede outside of
school, thinking about that.
Can't wait to get home,
put my hustle head down,
get that Primo.
And everyday coming home from school, man,
If I didn't see nobody running,
I'll go by my damn self and go get it.
And, with that came trouble,
because I became more reckless.
It had more control over me,
in a short period of time.
And before you know it,
I was homeless by 18,
three years of messing
around, dipping and dabbing.
I was on the streets,
everybody like, oh hell, nah.
This boy is got bad.
He's too bad man, he's a
wild man running around.
You know, and I'd be missing
in action three, four days,
two, three weeks and
all that kind of stuff.
And I remember, my mom
taking me to church one time.
And so, she said, to go to the altar
if you have trouble and all that.
So, I go to the front and I'm standing up
and the pastor, you know, hit my.
Mind you, everybody
before me, I'm in line.
So, I'm watching every time she touch
somebody on the head, they fall out.
Get to me, you know, push
me back a little bit,
I don't fall.
'cause I don't feel like it.
So, she do it again.
Okay, I go ahead and fall
out, have somebody catch me
and I'm shaking and convulsing
and slobbering at the
mouth and all that stuff.
After I get up,
we get back home, I say, mom,
I'm getting ready to
go to the store, right?
Check it out, I have $5
I was supposed to put in the plate.
Hell nah, I'm keeping that $5.
I say, when you get back to
the house to say, Hey mom,
I'm going down the street
to get a pack of cigarettes,
I'd be right.
And was gone for three weeks.
'cause it killed me that I had to,
I didn't feel like falling.
I didn't feel nothing, but I
had to go through that pony,
that show and tell, you know,
and it just crushed me on the inside,
because I'm like, man,
this ain't real, what the.
I was gone for three weeks,
last time I went to church.
They didn't take me to
church from after that.
'cause they knew how it affected me.
I didn't wanna to fall, I
didn't feel like falling,
everybody else did, but I
didn't feel like passing out
and all that bullshit, but I did it.
And after I was gone for them
three weeks, that was it.
They didn't invite me to church
no more, 'cause they knew.
Now, he got to see his own
way up out of this one.
And so, what happened was, everybody said
my saving grace was jail.
Anyway, I did nickel and dime
stuff, breaking into cars,
stealing hubcaps,
battery, stuff like that.
Getting the things off the license plates,
the years, the little things
with a razor blade and
all that kind of stuff.
So, that's what I was doing, man.
Stealing bicycles, lawn
mowers and people's, you know,
whatever man, whatever
was around, you know.
You know, if I can get
it, it was a done deal.
You know, my specialty was stores.
You know, clothing stores, you know,
shops then, centers, whatever.
And so, everybody thought my
saving grace was the jail.
So, I'll be gone first time
they're like, eight months county.
Then I caught a strong armed robbery,
because I demanded some money from a guy
and he didn't wanna give it up.
So, I fought him for it and I lost,
but they gave me a strong armed robbery
and I did 16 months in prison.
Went to fire camp.
They had weights back then,
so, you know, working
out and I'm in fire camp,
I'm fighting these fires
and all that kind of stuff.
So, I come home and I'm this
like, this new creation.
Now, mind you, I got 16 months,
I've been gone 10 months.
So, I come back to the old neighborhood
and I say within two days, I'm
back right where I left off.
Picked up, right where I left off.
And I'm like, how in
the fuck did I get here?
How did I get in this bad shape this soon?
Because I didn't know that
emotionally and mentally
I was the same old scared kid,
same old one scared of his own shadow,
had all the stiffest stuff
going on in side of me,
even away from home, it was driving me,
I couldn't sleep at night.
I was having nightmares and
dreams and this and that,
about what awaited me and not dreaded it.
If I could have went anywhere else,
but my neighborhood, when
they released me from prison,
I would have, but I couldn't
admit that to nobody,
'cause I knew what was waiting on me.
I knew what was waiting.
And it only got worse
before it got better.
It got more dangerous
being on the streets.
You know, the killings was more rampant.
The police was around more.
The crack done took over
the whole neighborhood,
everybody was on it.
Shit, they had a crack
house, every other house,
seemed like in my neighborhood,
not on every corner,
but every other house.
Somebody is smoking it,
somebody's selling it.
Shit, I couldn't escape
that if I want it to.
Everywhere I turn.
Oh yeah, they got over here,
yeah, they got the good stuff over here.
Oh man, check this out, how
long have you been gone?
Oh yeah, you're going
to love this one, man.
And they got the new methods of
when you smoke it now they, man,
hold your neck and all that kind of stuff.
You take a hit, hold it and grab you
on the side of your neck
and all that bullshit.
Okay, since you blow it out,
you pass out and hit
your head and all that.
Man, I went through all of that, you know,
in the name of of getting
that effect, you know,
getting that Boo yaw!, that good one.
You know, in the
beginning it was fun, man.
It was something different.
You know, it took me away,
it gave me everything.
It did stuff for me, man.
Words can't describe what it
did, but it did something.
Until this day, I can't
describe it in words,
but whatever it was, it
was enough to hold me
and keep me in it's grips almost 30 years.
So, I had this love, hate
relationship with crack cocaine.
It was my best friend, then
it became my worst enemy
and I've been going to prison, man,
and when I'm going to prison and okay, so,
I think second time, working
out, still working out,
so I come home, like the rock.
And I remember, I think after
my six, seven, eighth trip
of going and coming back on fucking swole.
They said, oh man, you
look like a superhero, man.
You just got the fucking
perfect body, like God damn.
I said, Oh yeah, I know where to go now.
You now what I mean.
When it gets too hard on the streets
where I just can't take
it, I'm know where to go.
Where I can rest, just take a chill,
get away from the bullshit.
And then, with the family
thing, the gang thing
and the crack thing, I
know where to escape,
I know where to go, get
away from all this bullshit
and that's what I did.
When it's time for me to check out,
you're showing that, yes I did.
Man, I'll do something to get in trouble,
'cause I just got tired
of dealing with that shit
on the streets, man, I need
a car gone take me away.
And here they come, in a
form of a black and white
police car.
Man, what took you motherfuckers
so long, hurry up man.
Can't take no more of this
over here, driving me crazy.
You know, so, even though it felt like
problems, everything was
compounding and packing upon me,
you know, but I did what I did best
and that was run, escape.
I knew how to escape.
If it was through drugs and alcohol,
it was through leaving the streets,
going to that other place,
my home away from home,
which I spent more time
in prison over the years
than I did on the streets
and that's reality
before it was all said and done.
So, being out here was
my home away from home,
that was my real home, almost 30 years.
Because I went back.
I remember coming home,
staying home for two days
and went right back, after two days.
Two days, my momma said, Oh man,
I couldn't believe that,
I couldn't believe you,
you were only here for two days.
How much stuff three years would have,
21 months, oh that ain't nothing mama.
That's what I said.
You know, master up this false courage,
oh that ain't nothing, I
can do that on my head.
Man, but today it was something,
because instead of bonding and building
a healthy, loving
relationship with my siblings.
Every time I disappeared,
my time away from home
got longer and longer.
So, went from 16 months,
four years, three years.
Did all the violations in between.
So, instead of building relationships
with my sister, my brother,
things just got worse.
Every time I came home,
it's the same shit going on,
but just turned up a notch or two.
So, it was more intense me and him.
It was more intense on my
smoking, on my hustling,
you know, it just turned that shit up
to a whole nother level.
And man, I was always
trying to play catch up,
I always playing catch up,
I always trying play catch up,
I'm always behind, I always
trying to find my way,
never get through some shit.
What's going on, man, it
changed over here, man,
it changed over there, man,
so-and-so ain't here no more,
oh, this three ain't here
no more, oh this changed,
I'm like what?
I'm like, man, felt like
I was in the stone age.
Every time I leave and come back home,
I was getting that further,
further, further behind.
I didn't have no relationship,
a real relationship
with my mom, my sister, my brother.
My nephews come along,
I don't have no relationship with them.
I'm their uncle, I love them.
But I'm gone through both
of my nephews childhood.
You know, and my sister
was a single parent
and I was thinking man, to be an uncle,
to have opportunity to
deal with my nephews.
You know, it was a dream come
true when she first had Chris,
excuse me, my nephew.
Then we she had the other
one, it's like, wow,
I wasn't there for him, but
I'ma be there for this one.
That's a damn lie,
because I wasn't, I didn't,
I wasn't able to be there
like I wanted to, like
I needed to, you know.
And they had this old saying, you know,
following the footsteps of your dad,
you know, and he was the absentee.
And even though I didn't
have any kids on my own,
I was an absentee uncle.
And I thought it'd be a deterrent
for me wanting to mess up,
but after about my fourth,
fifth trip to prison,
I'm like, man, this shit ain't nothing,
it wasn't no deterrent.
Oh, man, if you do this,
you're going go to prison.
Man, I don't give a fuck, I don't care,
prison don't scare me.
Smoke all the crack in California,
drink all the drinks, smoke all the weed.
Rob, still do what I do.
'cause it wasn't no
determined, it wasn't a factor
in me wanting to change and
try something different,
because by then, man, I was in too deep
and I was lost in a sauce, man.
So, even though now in retrospect,
man, I just went to that plantation, bro.
I went to the plantation, yes sir,
and I had to do they
motherfucking bidding, yes sir.
For a little bit of
nothing and I better did.
And if I didn't do it, there
were some consequences,
you know, all that kind of stuff, any who.
Man, so, I'm back and forth, you know,
working in the kitchen,
working for 3 cents, 5 cents,
7 cents an hour, you know.
At the end of the month
I get $14, you know,
I'm think I'm balling.
Wow, it's time to go to the canteen.
Porters fill out your canteen slip, man,
kitchen workers go early, we go first.
You know, 'cause you guys, you know,
service is up in here.
You know, you serve the people
and all that kinds of stuff, the inmates.
Okay, that's cool, that's cool.
You know, and get my little soups
and my little few bag of
chips and my honey buns.
And I'm like, wow, you know, I'm good.
You know, but I had a place
where I can go where I feel safe.
I had to worry about stuff,
but not to the degree
as on the streets, I didn't have the crack
around me, messing with
me and driving me crazy,
'cause I just had to have that shit
and I couldn't live without it.
I could live with it or without it.
I didn't have relationship with nobody
in my immediate family.
So, when I'm going to prison,
I just read, read, work out
and worked in a kitchen, you know.
And out of all those trips to prison man,
I learned that, there was some things
that I had to address
when I was there, man.
And the biggest one
for me was self-hatred.
I wouldn't admit it, but I hate it man,
I hated me, I hated being black,
because of the circumstances,
man, that I was brought up in.
Yeah, you tell me how I'm doing,
no, I'm good, man, I'm fine,
yeah, everything is okay,
soul brother, peace and all that bullshit.
Truth be told, I couldn't
stand being black,
poor and in real trouble.
You know, and I just saw
the writing on a wall, man.
I'm like, Oh man, I see
what I'm destined for.
By the way things are lining up
and I saw that shit early
on in the game, saw it.
It wasn't nothing that can
stop me from going that route.
I didn't have enough role models,
didn't have enough people that really care
about the next man.
We was all in the same boat,
everybody was poor and
discordant and depressed
and all that bullshit.
We wouldn't talk about it as kids.
You know, running around with holey shoes
and all that bullshit, hand
me down clothes and all that.
I remember I used to walk to school,
walking to school sliding my foot,
because in both of my
shoes, I had big ass holes
at the bottom of them, I used
to put newspaper court board.
So, I'm walking to school,
one and slide in the one.
Soon as I would lift my foot up,
somebody it get them talking
and they'd get the laugh and a clowning
and all that kind of stuff.
Man, I used to like hate that shit man,
And having pants that were too small,
so, I have to wear them way down here,
at they call sagging today,
but I was doing that shit
way back in the days, because
the pants were hand me down,
they were given to me, you know, so,
having other kids and look
at me a certain kind of way
when I'm in school,
'cause I was busted to the Valley schools.
So, they used to give me that look.
And I knew what that look meant, you know,
Oh, feel sorry for this dude.
You see how those little lunch things,
for food, you know, for the
lunches and breakfast and stuff.
And people used to get on the other side
with their little change and dollars.
And used to get over here
with the meal tickets man.
And wasn't no shame in
the game or nothing,
you know, 'cause I ain't tripping.
You know, shit, free, paid, don't matter.
You know, if I had some change,
I'd rather use the ticket,
because I can keep the
little dollar and a quarter,
whatever it was, you know, that
I saved from not buying it.
So, that really didn't bother me.
But just the looks that
I got, knowing that
it wasn't so much as how they
saw me, or what they said
or what they thought, but more so,
what I've thought and felt about me.
And that's where the self
hatred came in there.
'cause there was in the gut,
there wasn't a damn
thing I can do about it.
You know, and the only
thing I could do was run.
Tuck my tail and run
and I just added to it.
I couldn't stand up for myself.
I couldn't fight for me or nothing,
unless I had the marijuana, the alcohol,
you know, and whatever that
would induce with the crack,
that just amplified all the other stuff
that I was holding in, you know.
So, on that shit just
almost drove me crazy,
you know, because I
just couldn't, you know,
I smoke so much man, and did so much, man.
But if it wasn't for prison,
I would have been dead or
would have been on deed
and that's the God's honest truth.
Prison saved my life.
And then, in another sense, you know,
I found myself in there, I found me.
You know, 'cause I ran
there thinking I was hiding
and escaping my reality,
but that's where I found solace man.
That's where I had time to
really do some soul searching.
I remember one year I went to prison,
I think it was, I forgotten.
Anyway, I read all black history books,
Before the Mayflower, The Middle
Passage and all that stuff.
I said, wow man, great contributions.
This, this, I said, wow.
And that kind of changed my mind about me,
because in school,
being been busted Valley
and all white folks, we reading,
this is elementary, junior
high, history books.
The first two pages of
every book was on slavery.
The first two pages, slavery.
So, I'm two, three black
kids up in here, man.
And we reading about this shit.
If I can turn red, I
would have turned red,
but I think I must have
turned purple every time
the history class re-read
about the slavery.
Man, that was the first,
the beginning of every history book, man,
that's what started with, I'm like, God.
I say, can't they put this in
the middle, towards the end,
because this is the
starting off place, man,
and all eyes is on me.
I'm like, uh, duh.
And I hated that, I hated it, man,
I hated being in that predicament man,
of being one of the few
token black kids man,
at this white school, man.
In history class, speaking on,
it just does something to me, man.
And even to this day, it bothers me,
but not as much as it did back then.
I didn't have nobody to talk to back then.
You know, I didn't mess with nobody
in elementary and junior high,
I was alone that end too.
I stayed to myself, did my own thing,
talk to a few people, but pretty much
didn't building no relationships
and nothing like that,
didn't have no friends back then.
But, yeah man, it was just,
in prison I read all those books,
start to see things different and then,
I guess when the student's
ready, the teacher appears.
So, I think after like,
19 trips to prison, my saving grace.
Thank you, I didn't say it
back then, but now I do.
I was really ready for that
change from the inside out.
I knew something had to be different,
because I have been going so many times.
I knew if something didn't
happen this last time,
that I was just gonna be,
that's it, it's a wrap, you know.
And what happened was,
the last time, you know,
I went to the same prison
three times in a row.
went back to back, to back, to back,
same one, back, back, back, the same one.
So, all three times that
they see me come and go,
see me come, like damn,
you're back again, yeah.
The third time, I did the same thing
I did the other two times.
I did the self-help classes,
I did the Islamic services,
I did the church, I did all that stuff.
Worked out like I did, I've been doing,
'cause it worked for me, it helped me.
Shit, I'm not gonna stop
doing what helped me
while I was in there.
I went to the library, I read
all the books that I can find.
I love autobiographies.
I got burnt out on black history,
because my whole prison term,
I read none but that, so,
I was like, I'm good, I don't
have to read another page,
I don't have to hear
about another contribution
that we made back, I'm good.
You know, I'm good, I'm okay with me now.
You know, so, the self-hatred left me,
but I carried that a long time.
And I used to trip on how, even down here
when I see the young black
men and I see that look.
Oh, I know that look, I had the same look.
I had that same look, anger, the despair,
I'm gonna tear somebody's
head off, that was me.
I know what it is 'cause
I went through it.
Made it to the other side, what
a blessing, what a blessing.
But self realization is the best one.
And only way you're going to learn that
is by your own experience,
'cause your own experience is
gonna be your best teacher.
I read many books on black history,
but me living as a black man
in California, Los Angeles.
Back in the time of the gangs,
the crack and all that bullshit epidemics.
You know, man, that's a
story in itself, you know,
I should write a book
on surviving the streets
of Los Angeles during the 80s,
that worst time of my life.
And it was out of my control, you know.
And, so, what happened was, man,
the last time something had to happen
and I did everything I did the last time,
but it said, when the students are ready
the teacher will appear.
And lo and behold, I had many
teachers appear my last term
and they just fed me, they
just feed me different stuff.
You know, year, after year, after year,
I'm building these relationships within,
inside the prison, that I
never got to do on the streets.
You know, I got to build
these relationships
with these teachers that
didn't have with my sister.
I got to develop these relationships
with these men that didn't
have with my brother.
Never thought I'd get it there,
never thought I'd get the healing there,
never thought I'd be free there.
I was set free, from the
bondage and the bullshit
and all that stuff that
I was going through.
I was set free in there,
I was able to sit down,
build a relationship,
healthy, loving relationship
without no strings attached,
without no arterial motives.
All the bullshit I've been
through on the streets, man,
during the crack epidemic
and all the things I've done,
leading up to going to prison.
I needed a break from all that stuff,
especially when I was
doing my little thing
in the entertainment field.
I really needed to break from that shit
and I got it, man.
But it was building
up, it was building up.
So, once I said enough is enough,
it was already taking its toll on me.
So, when I got back and
started doing the same thing
over and over, end up in
prison that last time,
I was ready, man, because I
was away from it for so long
by working, you know,
audience kind of thing.
So, that kept me smoking, you know,
kept me smoking man.
Like, I was a Pied Piper,
kept money in my pocket,
I didn't have to ask nobody for nothing,
I took care myself,
supported my own habit,
right on, you know.
And that was like the Pied Piper.
You know, I'd come home
from doing me a scene
go back in the old
neighborhood, Hey, you, you,
come on, come on, let's go.
You know, I'm the man.
gimme something for 200.
Yeah, come on y'all.
Here, here, here.
Now, we smoke the
impunity, with them bandit.
I'm the motherfucking
man until I get broke.
Then once I'm broke, it's like, okay,
so, when are we supposed to do another,
Hey, I need some work, man.
You got anything set up for me?
Oh, two weeks from now.
Damn, you can't do nothing
earlier than two weeks.
That kind of thing.
So, since nothing could be set up,
where I can get some more
money to tide me over,
I had to resort back to the
stealing, stuff like that,
you know, them stores and
last time in prison, man,
I built something that money can't buy,
I found peace, I found serenity.
I had peace, money came by that
and it's so valuable.
I wouldn't trade it for
nothing in the world today.
Yeah, I had a missteps.
I've had missteps along
the way, since I've home.
Shit, I wish I was perfect.
Wish I could have said I got
through without stumbling.
You know, I always tell myself,
man, I have two left feet.
So, I have to be extra
careful when I walk,
'cause I don't have a, right and left.
So, it's more easier for me to fall,
trip or fall, 'cause I have two.
So, I have to be mindful,
extra careful, you know.
And, but we're somebody important, man,
aside from everything else, man.
No matter what goes on
in Marlborough today,
rain, shine, good, bad, in between.
I'm okay man, because I'm okay with me.
You know, I've found me.
I know my worth, my time is important.
I'm important, I'm somebody.
And I try to represent to the
best of my abilities, man.
I'm not special, I'm not unique.
What I put out there, just try
to put something out there,
just so you know, when you
look, you do the double take,
for whatever reason, it
might be the muscles,
I don't know what it is
and really don't care,
but I will want it to be something good
for me making a difference
in some kind of way.
Not by how I look or
all that kind of stuff,
but what I contribute,
what I bring, you know,
to the day, to the real,
to my family, to my friends
and so forth and so on.
You know, I can count
my friends on one hand
and I met them in prison.
And still have a relationship up in today
and it is a beautiful, man.
I never imagined that I
would be okay with me,
that I would be okay with all
the things I've been through
man, all of the things
that put my family through.
All of the hurt I caused
and all the kind of stuff
to family and to myself, man.
'cause if somebody would have did me
like I did myself growing up,
I would've killed they
ass and been doing life.
If somebody would have
did me the way I did me.
So, now, when I wake up in the morning,
I look in the mirror, I
notice who's looking back.
I take notice who's looking back.
And I said, you know what?
That person's dependent on me.
That person needs me.
And I got to be there for that person.
Got to be there 100%.
I got to bring my a game,
because he's all like got.
And I swear I roll today, uncut.
Fair exchange ain't no robbery.
Okay.
- [Mark] Take care.
- Okay.